man it's not very often where i'm
envious of somebody's man cave
but chris webber joining us now
i don't know how you'd describe that
home jim seaweb but man that looks like
it's right out of a movie set
uh yeah uh yeah i brought it from
hoosiers but no
um tell you what it's pretty but it
doesn't get any more use anymore so
so it looks good it's it's like a prop
but nobody's in there
in the lab working i don't know if
anybody's had a good game in here
probably about eight years so it's been
a while
best player who's played in there beside
you oh
rip hamilton uh matt
rip rip hamilton probably rip he used to
he used to make this his place a lot so
uh rip this is rip's gym man that is
sharp looking right out of a movie
um all right the documentary on michael
jordan what stood out to you when
you watched assuming you watched yeah i
watched actually i've been watched uh
the last three days
i i couldn't watch during the beginning
because
after the first episode i didn't see it
was so much debate i was just like i'll
go crazy as a jordan fan staying
up to the moment on this so i just
waited and um
it was everything you know that i
thought and more
uh great you know for some disappointing
at times but
i was the biggest michael jordan fan
that there was and um
you know it just just uh made you feel
good about those moments in your life
the things that you were doing at those
times the best memories that you had
and attached those to kind of michael
jordan's life soundtrack so it was
pretty cool to watch
anything bother you i mean you know i'm
a pistons fan
you know so um
not necessarily between him and zeke you
know because because i know that
they have that thing and zeke is
definitely a mentor and a friend
and uh i only had hoped jordan would be
that you know growing up
but the narrative on the pistons
um just being bully ball
it was funny to me because if you really
look at it new york
the next team was trying to be the
pistons right but they didn't have
lambert
who was shooting threes i think he made
three four five three-pointers
in a quarter so it wasn't just like come
down post up they didn't have that team
you know so um i thought the pistons
were a lot smarter than they were
depicted but at that time the rules were
rough
and uh but as a as a pistons fan i
didn't i didn't mind them walking off
tipton
by the boys and all that i didn't care i
didn't care but i enjoyed the doc and uh
probably my favorite part was uh
him uh winning the championship uh two
of my favorite moments
uh kg winning the championship saying
anything's possible
and uh jordan when he won the
championship uh
and he was holding it and uh you knew
his father wasn't there i remember
watching that game with my father i
remember how big of a moment it was and
uh
it it still plays as big that many years
later what was it like though that first
time you step on the floor
with the guy that you've idolized and
now all of a sudden
he's right there in front of you okay so
like say with him barkley you know bird
you're the greatest
players that i looked up to whether it
was because i first got a chance to play
against jordan of the dream team
and i'm telling you in the huddle my
eyes are watering
looking at other guys like this is our
moment and um
wait you're crying my eyes are watering
i'm not crying but
i mean i guess i i'm holding tears back
but this is a moment you know i'm
playing against my hero i mean
it's larry bird short and malone and
barkley over there man you know and i'm
looking at grant hill i'm looking at
rodney rogers and
um you know hurley and we're all looking
like man this
yeah this is yeah we're here this is
that moment we'll never forget
and um so playing against jordan and all
those greats
you know we grew up on them so the only
way to honor them
is to act like or to do what they put in
you and instilled in you so
even though you're the biggest fan
there's no time for hey jordan i love
you because that's not what he would
want there's no time for that with
barkley so what you try to do is emulate
what they would have done on the court
and um that's just try to fake it like
you're tough until you get off and call
your dad and be like man i played
against jordan
did you get embarrassed uh no we we beat
the dream team the first day
and then uh the next day we didn't score
so we
we got embarrassed but after we got
embarrassed after we reached the
mountaintop so we didn't care man
but this was summer of 92.
is that right it was my going into my
sophomore year after my freshman year i
believe yes so it's a group of college
all-stars against the dream team
scrimmaging yeah danny you got to
realize i mean i i know you know the
context but um
i wanted to play in the olympics yeah
you know we thought we were pretty good
but the
teams before that we had discussed it
kind of
uh with lackluster and so we you know it
wasn't our chance and so i'm talking to
coach daley and
uh david stern and them just saying how
important this moment is in history and
how
our favorite players are going to be the
ambassador for basketball around the
world we kind of understood yeah kids
like us
they'd rather see this than us so we'll
wait our turn but um we knew it was a
we knew it was a big moment man but uh
watching jordan you
going in his room seeing the music he
played watching him play tonk
um scottie pippen taking us to dinner
um it was just what i learned playing
against the olympic team was that
the nba players really are fans of the
college players and they really want you
to come in and do well
just not against them and so it was cool
it was cool you know seeing their
generosity but also
feeling the wrath of that anger after
you uh after you run out the gym up one
and coach turns the clock off and
and the lights are what did you think
when laitner got that spot on the dream
team
i thought that shaq was a better
player would be a better player but
christian leighton was by far a better
college player
christian leighton is
kareem christian leitner in in my age
group my demographic for players that
i've seen is the best college player
to step on the floor period and so
i wanted some of him in those practices
and scrimmages but it was barkley malone
and other guys but i didn't
i didn't feel any type of way i thought
it was a good political move for the nba
a college player four years was going to
be a high draft pick
and again i mean christian layton got
buckets and went to championship so
we got to put that in perspective
christian leighton is one of the best
college players that we've ever seen in
this game
yeah i agree with you on it i just
didn't know how how competitive that
final
spot was for college players and as you
said
shaq should have been up for it you
could have been up for it but leitner is
one of the more decorated college
players of all time
and you know we always look at hey how
did he do as a pro
it's like the guy who wins the heisman
chris and then they go yeah but he
wasn't a good pro
therefore it diminishes what he did in
college and i always say
leightoner was a better than average he
was a borderline
good player nba player good player in
the nba he was great in college he
manned up every time you needed a big
shot big game he never
backed down from anybody from you guys
to larry johnson
unlv whatever the challenge was later
stepped up
and he didn't back down the nba because
people were trying to give him that work
that they owed him from college this
whole time in the league
so no he he he did a great job i just
think
we have to really remember the context
of that time and i know you guys know
remember shaq should have started the
all-star game
i mean he should have started the
augusta gate his rookie year and
remember
that patrick ewing and those guys said
no rookies start the game i mean back
then there was such
a pecking order that um shaq freed us
from
you know when shaq after he did that
what do you see other guys come in then
you see yao getting the most votes even
though
yes international but it still
wasn't um it wasn't anybody saying oh
you can't do that because it was the
business of basketball and we're like
come on bring the best
and no matter what age they are you
don't have to be in the league this long
to be an all-star all you got to do is
go to work right now
here's chris webber five-time all-star
nba on tnt analyst former nba
all-star you've told us some jordan's
stories
uh when you guys face them in the
playoffs
uh didn't he did he drive up and did he
have a ferrari or lamborghini
and and was he waiting for you guys on
the team bus
so dan i'm very happy that they showed
jordan with the cigars as much as he
smoked
because i've told this story i think i
told you guys and no one wants to
believe it because
a cohiba i mean try playing golf
the second line is terrible if i spoke
no
it'll make you dizzy you get lightheaded
come on i mean i i knew baseball players
that dipped i knew
like that is real and so yeah we're
coming in i don't i
don't want to mess it up with missing
out on what game it was but we're
playing against the bulls
the best team ever 72. uh juwan
uh from chicago worked out with jordan a
lot i'm a big fan of jordan
and i knew like with him you don't put
on a blindfold and a cigarette like just
open your eyes and take it and enjoy the
moment just
just just go and so
i really feel i'm a really good teammate
because
i i was always about my teammates that
was my goal to get you the ball to make
sure because they do so much for you and
this is the one day i wasn't a good
friend or a teammate we get
we pull into the boys arena right up
under there where you're parking you can
see little restaurants and everything
and
getting off of my suit and my bag you
know in in game mode and jawan is in
front of me walking off the bus
i'm talking junk to him whispering in
his ear and we get off the bus and
directly across
like a cartoon like like a movie like
shaft
yeah he was like like jordan was sitting
back on the ferrari
smoking a cigar before the game and this
in this series i think they
we played them three games and they only
beat us by seven points total
so we thought you know we thought we
would have stuff and um
we get off and uh he goes hey webb
who's checking me and i looked at jawan
and we both looked back at calvary
chaney and did like this
that was so whack of us man that was so
wrong with us man
and i think he gave us 53 55 or
something
something like that it was so crazy i
remember telling juwan when uh
jordan was on the free throw line i was
like he sold his soul
he sold his soul to the devil to be good
in basketball
and he looked at me like maybe i did
maybe i didn't
you weren't on the team with lebradford
smith were you when when mike singled
him out were you still
at michigan yeah i was still in michigan
i wasn't i wasn't there for that beat
down
poorly bradford smith he didn't do
anything
he said nice game and then mike used
that as a slight
and did he really even say nice game who
knows bradford smith has a son going dad
why'd you say that to mike he's like son
listen i really didn't
yeah yeah one of the best competitors
ever and i tell you what it was um
it was it was an honor to compete
against tim and kobe in the same way
because
everything was on the table you knew
that you you knew their incentive their
arterial motives their motivation
you just honestly knew what it was and
it was rather refreshing to know
this is what you're going up against you
would start thinking about him
three four games before you started to
play him
and um all you want to do is beat him
and and win every possession so if you
did get a steal you better talk junk and
enjoy that moment because
whether you do or don't he's going to
come back and take it out on you anyway
so
it was it was an honor to play against
in my opinion you know
the greatest of all time and also you
know people want to make this comparison
with lebron
and michael and i said if you want to
make a comparison make the comparison
with kobe
because they are similar lebron is not
close to michael as far as his approach
to the game his personality
kobe was an alpha dog i mean he but he
learned from mike as he said
hey i'm i'm who i am because of michael
he wanted to be michael lebron can't be
michael
he's more magic than michael but we keep
trying to
hey we got to have this conversation
this debate this argument
and yeah and it's it's hard to debate
that i i could debate kobe and mike more
than i can lebron
yeah you definitely can i can too
because we all know that kobe wanted to
be my the vulnerability
um you know talking like mike the
interviews everything's a challenge i
used to tease him about
and he wanted that um and i i really
think we need to appreciate the
evolution of players
because if if it wasn't for magic
there'd be no lebron in my opinion
magic six nine dribbling the ball lebron
the same way
lebron makes the correct basketball play
and yet he's been criticized
every single time you know there were
some things in the doctor that exposed
mike's attitude and whether you like it
or not that's your opinion
and we see lebron's attitude every day
whether he trusts
kyrie for a last shot or some would say
need him for a last shot but jordan said
he needed pippin
so you know to me lebron is a mixture of
michael
and magic because he has the athletic
ability of
michael and the willingness to pass
and get others involved uh like magic
and it was something that we
we really hadn't seen and i think i
heard pippin or someone say when
lebron has the ball everyone on the
floor is open because you have to watch
start
guarding him but you also have to watch
your man and not let
lebron be a decoy by having all the eyes
on him so i agree with you it's an
unfair
comparison and uh but i tell you what uh
all three of those guys
are they're pretty good they're pretty
good they're okay give me a kobe story i
don't know
wow a kobe store you don't know
i don't know how good of a story this is
but not to
to waste time thinking about it i
remember um don't know what year
was uh it was the afro kobe
it was afro-kobe he was paulie but wait
hold on chris
paulie check the afro kobe what year
that would have been 99 i think it's 99
but i'll check
okay so that's a good stats you know you
know the game but uh he had
the year before he had been criticized
or someone said something about him
being weak in the fourth quarter
it was we went to dinner or something
and he brought this up and i'm looking
at him
i'm like we're really going to talk
about this now and so
whatever it was in passing and so we
played them
um sacramento we used to always used to
play them in the preseason in vegas or
something
and so i hadn't seen kobe in a while and
he'd text me or something and uh
we run it out we run a play the first
couple plays of the game he comes by
bang
and he hits me real hard i'm looking i'm
like what's wrong with you man comes
back bang he hits me real hard just
so at halftime he's like you feel that
i'm getting stronger right i'm getting
stronger right
and i mean it was from our conversation
i think the greatest thing about those
is like how
i've heard that a great picture you have
to not have a great memory
you know you can't remember the guy that
hit a home run on you focus on the next
one
the great things about those guys they
never let anything go even if it is
um like i used to have a superstition
that you can't have a superstition that
was my only superstition if you play a
great game in these shoes so what don't
play in them again because
nothing can get in your mind like so
what the shoes didn't do it and for
kobe and jordan those guys i think that
their memory
um and motivation their memory came from
their motivation even if it was off a
successful game
challenging themselves to out through
that game last time and so
it's definitely a winner's mentality
with those kids we playing basketball
here soon
i was going to ask you i hear so much i
i don't
i don't know what do you think i think
they're going to try to pull this
together in orlando
and maybe use vegas for the west coast
teams but
it feels like you only get one shot at
this chris
you know that's the thing they and you
got to do it right
because if somebody tests positive or
something goes wrong here
then the season's done so i i like that
the commissioner stayed quiet
haven't heard anything from him in three
weeks and that's a good thing
i i i get the feeling they're gonna
they're gonna give this a go here in the
next couple of weeks trying to get them
to get everybody together
well i love the fact that our league and
our players union stay
in constant contact i think we have
great leadership from chris paul
and from silver on both sides i do
uh dan i do worry about it um
i would like to see regardless of this
year i would like to see the season and
i've stated this many times
start in december yeah around christmas
so we don't have to compete
so that we can with football so we can
take about 10 to 15 to 20 games off so
that old guys like myself can quit
complaining saying
oh you know jordan played 82 games rest
doesn't matter i think
you know this moment in time could be
the line in the sand
and with lebron he's the ultimate he's
not even a basketball player he's an
ambassador
so you know being that he played 82
games him being the guy that comes in
and now plays 70
now plays and ushers in this new era i
think would be cool i'm more worried
about
or more looking forward to the product
next year um i would be excited if
basketball is played this year but
guys have not been playing so we're
gonna see a little rustiness with that
what do you do with teams that
could make it in if a guy like myself
that's been in 15 years
and each year is just one time to win
the championship yeah
even if i'm in 11th place you got to let
me try to play to get in the playoffs or
at least that's my argument
and so it's just um man i'm just not
envious
of the people in the position to make
decisions now because like you said
uh one one thing goes wrong and uh
it won't be good but i do trust the
league and i do trust the
players to to make sure they put their
best efforts forward and whatever the
decisions made
chris it's always great to talk to you
we appreciate your time hope you're
feeling well
and uh hopefully we get some basketball
y'all on quarantine like all in
all in the same house like my god we're
staying together since like march
together like three months that's a
reality show you know what i mean and we
get to see you in the studio now you're
not
no no no no there would be murder and uh
yeah we couldn't do it yeah it wouldn't
be good for
murder no i wouldn't or be or be
murdered
yeah that's probably it oh they'll just
duct tape you and just have it hold you
for ransom
thank you chris thank you guys that's
chris webber